Good Morning John!
It is 2015 meaning...
nothing.
The orbit of the Earth is an ellipse; there's
no point on it that is the beginning of that
ellipse.
The Earth's day has nothing to do with the
Earth's year.
We catch a glimpse of this when we wake up
in the morning and it's already New Year's
in Australia.
We're all like, "Well, I mean, what, but,
come on!"
The perils of living in a global culture,
John.
We don't get to ignore all of the seemingly
fundamental things that are actually totally
arbitrary and just made up.
So that's what I'm going to talk about today
here on the second day of 2015: just a short
list of things that seem intractable but are
totally made up.
Gendered Names: Allison, Hazel, Ashley, Carol.
They all seem like girl names to us but 100
years ago they were more commonly used for
boys.
Alphabetical Order: There's nothing special
about 'A' that makes it go first.
The alphabet is seemingly just completely
randomly ordered.
All the vowels are mixed in; most commonly
used letters are at the beginning and the
end.
There are some things that have order, like
'U', 'V', and 'W' are together because they
were all once one letter.
The interesting thing about this completely
arbitrary order of letters, though, is that
we've been using it roughly the same for over
3,000 years.
That's longer than any of the words in our
language have existed.
If you're wondering why they're in that order,
no one knows.
Base 10: When we count we do 0, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, and then we get to 10 and we
take the 1 again and put a zero after it.
There's no reason why that has to happen at
10.
It could happen at 12.
It could happen at 18.
It could happen at 3.
It could happen at 5.
Binary is when it happens just after the 0
and the 1.
Base 10 isn't special at all.
It's actually probably more annoying than
some other systems we could use.
Base 12 might be better.
We, in fact, use base 12 a lot when we talk
about dozens.
Probably we use base 10 just because we have
10 fingers.
That's the reason.
Bugs Are Gross: The culinary preferences of
different cultures are wildly diverse.
Now we think that the idea of consuming grub
is just, no, just bleaaagh.
But 80% of studied cultures eat insects so
we are, in fact, the weird ones.
Pets are Cute: Lots of cultures think that
we are crazy for letting animals live inside
of our house, and when my dog comes in from
the yard after stepping in her own poop, I
kind of agree with them.
Dirty Dancing: If the pole is horizontal,
that's gymnastics.
If the pole is vertical, that's stripping.
Guys Can't Wear Skirts: There's absolutely
no reason why men's legs have to be confined
to separate cloth cylinders.
Of course, I have seen this norm broken, but
not without feeling that little bit of, like,
"Wow, this is weird" feeling that you get
when you see a norm being broken.
Money: This is a piece of paper.
It's a very fancy piece of paper but it's
just a piece of paper.
There's nothing that makes this worth $20
except that we just sort of agree.
This becomes weird to me when I see these,
$2 bills, which are worth $2, like, they're
a legitimate currency, but they look fake
to me.
They look like they...
no.
Weirdly enough, I like $2 bills.
I hate $1 bills, but twos...
It's just 'cause they're weird.
Even weirder, nowadays there's actually a
number on a hard drive somewhere, then that's
the thing that decides whether or not I can
buy food or a house or a Tesla or a yacht.
This video is just a few silly examples, but
by forming our language, culture very literally
controls our thoughts.
We can't think with words that we don't have.
It's hard to separate yourself enough from
culture to be able to examine it.
If you separate yourself too much it can be
really uncomfortable.
I have been there!
It is!
We need culture, we need norms, we need there
to be an order to the alphabet and for there
to be a first day of the year.
But there are some bits that, while being
convenient, are not innocuous, and it is our
job to pick those out and say "You!
This don't belong here anymore."
That's something that we can do but only if
we take the time to step back and examine
our culture, which is best done by examining
other people's cultures.
Which is why, if you can, you should study
broadly and deeply and watch Crash Course
World History.
And all of Crash Course.
And also SciShow.
And yeah.
Okay.
John, thank you for your amazing video on
racism this week.
If people haven't scene it, you can go check
it out, youtube.com/vlogbrothers.
That's where we're at.
Okay, John, I'll see you on Tuesday.